This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，剖析展现精神坚韧、体能以及培养复原力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上搜索并订阅数字2。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的课》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有牌照的专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难成长的课》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临着
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are diving into a fascinating, increasingly prevalent aspect of modern life, we're talking about parasycial relationships.
后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析20多岁时的心理学。今天，我们将深入探讨现代生活中一个迷人且日益普遍的方面，我们要聊的是拟社会关系。
You might be thinking, what in the world is a parasocial relationship? I can almost guarantee that you've experienced one. Have you ever felt a very strong connection to a YouTuber or a podcaster whose voice you hear every week? Do you follow a specific celebrity on Instagram and are really invested in their relationship, in their friendships, in what they're doing personally.
你可能在想，到底什么是拟社会关系？我几乎可以向你保证，你一定经历过这种关系。你是否曾对某个YouTuber或播客主产生过非常强烈的情感连接？他们的声音你每周都能听到。你是否在Instagram上关注了某位特定的名人，并极度关注他们的恋爱关系、友谊以及他们的个人日常？
Do you find yourself genuinely happy or deeply sad based on what's happening in a fictional character's life from a TV show or from a book? Is there a musician you admire or someone you admire who you have been following for years? And their struggles and their triumphs feel like your own. If you answered yes, to any of those questions, congratulations, you have. have been in a parasycial relationship. A parasycial relationship is essentially a one-sided bond that we form with media figures, celebrities, fictional characters, even online influences. And in our 20s, this phenomena is particularly amplified. We are often very immersed in digital
你是否会因为一个虚构的角色——无论是来自电视剧还是书中——的生活中发生的事情，而感到由衷的快乐或深深的悲伤？有没有一个你钦佩的音乐家，或者某个你关注了多年的你崇拜的人？他们的挣扎和成功感觉就像是你自己的一样。如果你对上述任何一个问题回答了“是”，恭喜你，你曾经经历过拟社会关系。拟社会关系本质上是我们与媒体人物、名人、虚构角色甚至网络红人形成的一种单向纽带。在我们20多岁的时候，这种现象尤为明显。我们经常沉浸在数字
media. We are constantly consuming content. We are also really trying to find connection. So these seemingly safe and accessible connections that we have with fake versions of people that we see online are incredibly potent and meaningful. And it might sound a little bit abstract. Like how can you have a relationship with someone that you've never met? But there is a lot of psychology that proves that the feelings that we feel towards the celebrity figure are incredibly real. The excitement, the disappointment, the sadness, the grief, whatever it is, that we feel. towards someone in a public eye is felt deeply in our bodies and in our minds and in our brains. Sometimes this can even go very, very far, starting to stalk a celebrity.
媒体中。我们不断地消耗内容。我们也在极力寻找连接。因此，这些看似安全且触手可及的连接——我们与在网上看到的虚假人物版本建立的连接——具有极其强大的潜力和意义。这听起来可能有点抽象。你怎么能和一个从未见过面的人建立关系呢？但有很多心理学研究证明，我们对名人形象产生的感受是极其真实的。兴奋、失望、悲伤、哀痛，无论是什么，我们对公众人物产生的这种情感，都在我们的身体、心灵和大脑中被深深地感受到。有时这甚至会发展到非常非常极端的程度，开始跟踪某位名人。
We see examples of people who meet a famous singer and they touch them and they grab them because to them this person is familiar, but to the singer they are a stranger. We forget that. Think of like all these instances recently that have been happening with celebrities like Chaparone and Doja Cat. all of those examples come from it or derive from a parasocial connection that fans have with the people that they support. So we are going to explore what exactly is going on there. What's happening in our brains when we form these seemingly non-reciprocal bonds, how does social media really supercharge these connections,
我们看到了这样的例子：有人遇到了一位著名的歌手，他们去触碰他们、拉扯他们，因为对他们来说这个人很熟悉，但对歌手来说他们是个陌生人。我们忘记了这一点。想想最近发生在查佩尔·罗恩和多加·卡特等名人身上的所有这些事件。所有这些例子都源于或衍生自粉丝对他们支持的人所产生的一种拟社会连接。所以我们要去探索这其中到底发生了什么。在我们大脑中，当我们形成这些看似不对等的纽带时，到底发生了什么？社交媒体是如何真正给这些连接超级加码的？
how online personalities make you fall in love with them and make you connect with them from psychological perspective and why these relationships are often a form of escapism. I also want to talk about my own parasycial bonds. You know, I have relationships, relationships like these, if that's what we want to call them. And there's no shame here. I'm going to give you some insights to my own parasocial tendencies, the celebrities that I may worship and follow, just so that we can bear it all, we can have a really honest discussion around why this happens. It's so interesting. It's so fascinating. it is very much real. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of parasycial relationships.
从心理学的角度来看，网络红人是如何让你爱上他们并与你建立连接的，以及为什么这些关系往往是一种逃避现实的形式。我还想谈谈我自己的拟社会纽带。你知道的，我有这种关系，如果我们要这样称呼它们的话。这里没有什么好羞耻的。我将向你分享一些我对自身拟社会倾向的见解，那些我可能会崇拜和关注的名人，这样我们就可以坦诚相待，围绕为什么会发生这种情况进行一次真正诚实的讨论。这太有趣了。这太迷人了。它是非常真实存在的。那么废话不多说，让我们进入拟社会关系的心理学吧。
We have to begin by truly understanding what this relationship actually is, because it's not like a normal relationship, is it? Obviously, it's a parasycial one. So this term parasocial relationship, it wasn't just pulled out of thin air. It was specifically coined back in the 1950s by two pioneering sociologists. Donald Horton and Richard Wohl. It's really important to remember their names because they are the ones who really founded this whole idea.
我们必须从真正理解这种关系到底是什么开始，因为它不像普通关系，对吧？很显然，这是一种拟社会关系。所以“拟社会关系”这个词，并不是凭空捏造出来的。它最早是在20世纪50年代由两位开创性的社会学家创造的。唐纳德·霍顿和理查德·沃尔。记住他们的名字非常重要，因为他们才是真正创立了整个概念的人。
And they wrote this really influential paper. It was called Mass Communication and Parassocial Interaction, Observations on Intimacy At a Distance. And they were writing this paper, they were doing this research at a time when the media landscape was like rapidly changing. Television was like a relatively new phenomenon. a lot of people were only just starting to get TVs into their homes. People were getting hooked. You know, they never viewed or engaged with people this way, you know, through a screen.
他们写了一篇极具影响力的论文。它叫做《大众传播与拟社会互动：对远距离亲密关系的观察》。他们写这篇论文、做这项研究的时候，正值媒体格局迅速变化的时期。电视是一个相对较新的现象。很多人才刚刚开始把电视买进家里。人们迷上了它。你知道的，他们从未以这种方式——通过屏幕——看过或与人互动过。
And these researchers were meticulously observing how this was influencing our social minds, kind of out of fear, fear that it was changing who we were as creatures. I feel like that fear often comes with the introduction of any kind of new technology. and as they were doing this research, they noticed a very curious pattern. Viewers weren't just passively consuming content. They were, in a sense, engaging with TV personalities, news anchors, talk show hosts, actors, and they were engaging with them emotionally in a way that really mimicked real-life social interactions. Even though the audience obviously couldn't physically respond and they weren't being acknowledged,
这些研究人员一丝不苟地观察着这如何影响我们的社会心理，多少出于一种恐惧，担心这正在改变我们作为生物的本质。我觉得这种恐惧往往伴随着任何新技术的引入而产生。正当他们进行这项研究时，他们注意到了一种非常奇怪的模式。观众并不仅仅是被动地消耗内容。从某种意义上说，他们正在与电视名人、新闻主播、脱口秀主持人、演员进行互动，并且他们以一种极大地模仿现实生活中社交互动的方式在情感上与这些人互动。尽管观众显然无法做出物理上的回应，也没有得到承认，
they would still instinctively not along, they would smile, they would laugh, they would genuinely feel like they were having a personal interaction with the person on screen. They would even start bringing up characters or news anchor's names in conversations with family and friends, just like they were another person they knew. Like, oh, did you see that Dr. Phil got a new haircut? Oh, did you see that, you know, Nancy, her boyfriend broke up with her? They'd never met these people. All they knew about them was from TV.
他们仍然会不自觉地点头、微笑、大笑，真诚地觉得自己正在与屏幕上的人进行个人互动。他们甚至会开始在与家人和朋友的对话中提及角色或新闻主播的名字，就像他们是他们认识的另一个人一样。比如，“哦，你看到菲尔博士换新发型了吗？”“哦，你看到了吗，你知道的，南希和她的男朋友分手了。”他们从来没有见过这些人。他们对他们的了解全部来自电视。
a TV channel that thousands, millions of others were watching, and yet they couldn't help themselves. So these researchers described this as a very intimate personal connection that did not have two-way reciprocity, a one-sided relationship. It was a relationship that existed parallel to social interaction. You could see interaction between them and someone else taking place. You could imagine interacting with them, but it wasn't actually occurring. And that's where the term parasycial came from. Let's talk about some of the core characteristics that define these relationships and how to tell if you kind of may or may not have one. Parassocial relationships are always one-sided, always, but they are also incredibly emotionally engrossing. So this is arguably
一个成千上万、甚至数百万其他人都在观看的电视频道，然而他们却情不自禁。因此，研究人员将这描述为一种非常亲密的个人连接，但它没有双向的互惠性，是一种单向的关系。这是一种与社会互动平行的关系。你可以看到他们与其他人之间的互动正在发生。你可以想象与他们互动，但它并没有真正发生。这就是“拟社会”一词的由来。让我们来谈谈定义这些关系的几个核心特征，以及如何判断你是否可能拥有这种关系。拟社会关系永远是单向的，永远都是，但它们在情感上也极其引人入胜。所以可以说这是
the most critical and defining characteristic. In a genuine friendship or with a genuine person that you care about and you love, there's mutual recognition and interaction. However, in a parasocial relationship, the media figure has no personal knowledge of you whatsoever. You know about them, their life, their thoughts, their preferences, they have no awareness of your existence. And that feels very, very hard to grasp. This fundamental asymmetry is what sets these relationships apart from traditional social bonds. they also have a real powerful illusion of intimacy. So despite the lack of direct interaction,
最关键、最具定义性的特征。在一段真正的友谊中，或者与一个你关心和爱护的真正的人在一起时，存在着相互的认可和互动。然而，在拟社会关系中，媒体人物对你没有任何个人了解。你了解他们、他们的生活、他们的想法、他们的喜好，但他们对你的存在一无所知。这让人感觉非常非常难以理解。这种根本上的不对称性，正是将这些关系与传统社会纽带区分开来的地方。它们还具有一种非常强大的亲密感错觉。因此，尽管缺乏直接互动，
often there's a lot of information about this person that is accessible. Either they have made it accessible or, you know, certain news sites or tabloid magazines have made it accessible. So, for example, you know, someone like Taylor Swift, like people constantly talk about her dating life. And so you have this level of information about her that you wouldn't normally have about a stranger, but you also know that you don't actually know her. It's just that this level of information blurs the lines and it feels like you know all these intimate things. And so they are known by you. It can almost sound like, you know, you're on the receiving end of this media figure confiding in you. You know, all these things about their life, stuff that you would only know about someone if you
通常有很多关于这个人的信息是触手可及的。要么是他们自己让这些信息触手可及，要么是（你知道的）某些新闻网站或小报杂志让这些信息触手可及。所以，例如（你知道的），像泰勒·斯威夫特这样的人，人们总是在谈论她的约会生活。因此，你对她拥有了通常不会对陌生人拥有的信息量，但你也知道你其实并不认识她。只是这种信息量模糊了界限，让你觉得你知道了所有这些私密的事情。因此，他们被你所了解。这听起来几乎就像（你知道的）你是这个向你吐露心声的媒体人物的接收端。你知道关于他们生活的所有这些事情，只有当你
were close to them and yet you're not. Our brain kind of. gets confused. This emotional resonance, it's not superficial. Like, it is very real and it fosters loyalty and protectiveness. So this is another part about a parasycial relationship that people rarely talk about is the sense of loyalty, the fact that you would defend them to the ends of the earth, the fact that you are offended if someone else criticizes them, even though you don't know them, even though they don't know you. Because of this illusion of intimacy, and it is an illusion, there's also a non-reciprocal flow of information. So in a real relationship, information flows back and forth.
与他们很亲近时才会知道的事情，然而你并不是。我们的大脑有点。糊涂了。这种情感共鸣，并不是表面的。它非常真实，并能培养出忠诚感和保护欲。所以这也是拟社会关系中人们很少谈论的另一个部分，那就是忠诚感，你会誓死捍卫他们，如果别人批评他们，你会感到被冒犯，尽管你并不认识他们，尽管他们也不认识你。由于这种亲密感的错觉（而且它确实是一种错觉），这里还存在着信息的非互惠流动。所以在真实的关系中，信息是双向流动的。
You share something, they share something. You tell them a secret. They tell you a secret. You're vulnerable together. But again, you learn a lot about them. They don't know anything about you. And what it can sometimes lead to is people, you know, DMing famous celebrities, people sending them insane long emails,
你分享一些东西，他们也分享一些东西。你告诉他们一个秘密。他们也告诉你一个秘密。你们在一起变得脆弱。但同样地，你对他们了解很多。他们对你一无所知。有时这会导致人们（你知道的）给著名名人发私信，人们给他们发送疯狂的长篇电子邮件，
giving them all this information about them, almost to make it feel like they know them or meeting a celebrity and telling them like the most personal intimate thing about them because our brain is like, okay, we need to bridge the gap. It kind of understands that this is an illusion and it goes, well, the illusion will feel less severe if I start just telling people things. The thing is, is that you are one of thousands of people who DM a celebrity like Billy Eilish or a famous influencer. But you only see your message.
向他们提供关于他们的所有这些信息，几乎是为了让自己觉得他们了解他们，或者在遇到名人时告诉他们关于他们最私密的事情，因为我们的大脑会想：“好吧，我们需要弥合差距。”它有点明白这是一种错觉，然后心想，“嗯，如果我开始把事情告诉别人，这种错觉就不会那么强烈了。”问题是，你是成千上万给像比利·艾利什或著名网红这样的名人发私信的人之一。但你只能看到你的消息。
You only see what you're giving. And so the level of investment you put in, it's not matched. It cannot be matched, but it feels like a lot from your direction, whereas the other person still has no idea who you are. These relationships are also formed through repeated exposure. Consistency, as we know, is a key ingredient in the formula for perceived closeness for building any kind of relationship. Any relationship does not form overnight. It needs to be cultivated through consistent, repeated interactions, or in this scenario, repeated consumption of content, whether it's watching a show weekly, whether it's listening to a podcast
你只能看到你所付出的。因此，你投入的投资水平是不匹配的。它不可能匹配，但从你的方向来看感觉很多，而另一个人仍然不知道你是谁。这些关系也是通过重复接触形成的。正如我们所知，一致性是培养亲密感、建立任何类型关系的公式中的一个关键要素。任何关系都不会在一夜之间形成。它需要通过持续、重复的互动来培养，或者在这个场景中，通过重复消耗内容来培养，无论是每周看一次节目，还是听播客
daily, whether it is following and influences stories who post multiple times a day, this continuous exposure fosters familiarity, you know what's going on in their life, and a deep sense of closeness. That's a very natural reaction. The more frequently and consistently, you engage with their content, the stronger the feeling of a developed relationship becomes. That is why TikTok has done so well for making people famous, because it runs on people sharing as much of themselves as possible. It runs on people being content machines. And it gives that sense of consistency and exposure. This consistent presence, it also cultivates a real strong sense of anticipation, right? You're waiting for the next thing that they're going to talk about.
每天，无论是关注并观看一天发多次帖子的网红的故事，这种持续的接触都会培养出熟悉感（你知道他们生活中发生了什么），以及一种深厚的亲密感。这是一种非常自然的反应。你越频繁、越持续地与他们的内容互动，建立关系的感觉就会越强烈。这就是为什么TikTok在让人成名方面做得如此之好，因为它的运作基础是人们尽可能多地分享自己。它的运作基础是人们成为内容生产机器。它提供了这种一致性和接触感。这种持续的存在，也培养了一种非常强烈的期待感，对吧？你在等待他们要谈论的下一件事，
waiting for the next hall they're going to post, you're waiting for the next point of character development. Researchers have identified that this anticipation also strengthens an emotional investment in this person. You start to give them money, you start to buy their merchandise, you start to attend events, you start to subscribe for paid content, you start to give them more of your time. And this financial commitment, this investment of energy and time and resource, further solidifies the bond that you believe you have. Now, whilst this concept originated with very traditional broadcast media like TV and radio, of course, the digital age, it's just caused an explosion and a radical transformation of
等待他们发布的下一个开箱视频，等待角色发展的下一个转折点。研究人员发现，这种期待也增强了对这个人的情感投资。你开始给他们钱，你开始买他们的周边，你开始参加活动，你开始订阅付费内容，你开始给他们更多你的时间。这种财务承诺、精力和时间的投入，进一步巩固了你认为自己拥有的这种纽带。现在，虽然这个概念起源于非常传统的广播媒体，如电视和广播，但当然，数字时代已经导致了拟社会关系的大爆发和根本性转变，
parasocial relationships because you can now find any kind of person who looks like you, who has the same interests as you, you can kind of pick and choose who you want to relate to because there's so many internet personalities available, whereas previously, like, you kind of only had the traditionally famous individuals to choose from. Online personalities are also really unedited. They sell a highly authentic persona because they know that this is what people want to see. They know what scientists have been saying for a very long time. Either they know it from research or they know it through trial and error.
因为你现在可以找到任何长得像你、与你有相同兴趣的人，你可以挑选你想与之建立联系的人，因为有太多的互联网个性可供选择，而在此之前，你基本上只能在传统名人中进行选择。网络红人也是非常未经编辑的。他们出售高度真实的个性，因为他们知道这是人们想看到的东西。他们知道科学家长期以来一直在说的话。要么他们从研究中知道这一点，要么他们通过试错知道了这一点。
they know that when someone shares vulnerable information, when someone talks about the breakup, when someone posts blooper, reels, when someone films themselves without makeup, and when they maintain a consistent persona, through series, through whatever it is, they are often perceived as more relatable and trustworthy. As someone who has kind of been behind the scenes in this industry,
他们知道，当一个人分享脆弱的信息时，当一个人谈论分手时，当一个人发布花絮时，当一个人拍摄自己不化妆的样子时，当他们在整个系列、无论什么节目中保持一致的个性时，他们通常会被认为更具亲密感和可信度。作为这个行业幕后的一员，
I have to tell you, a lot of what you are seeing is not real. even if it looks really authentic, that authenticity has been created. Those interesting reels or those interesting storylines or those dramatic moments, those tea times, like a lot of it isn't real. People know that this is a marketing thing. This is a way to market themselves. Even if you think that you are immune to it,
我必须告诉你，你看到的很多东西都不是真的。即使它看起来非常真实，那种真实感也是被创造出来的。那些有趣的短视频、那些有趣的故事情节或者那些戏剧性的时刻、那些八卦（tea times），很多都不是真的。人们知道这是一件营销的事情。这是一种自我营销的方式。即使你认为你对它免疫，
the way that our brain works sometimes means that you're not. brains are very ancient organs and they are meticulously wired over millennia for social interaction and I guess survival within a tribal context. For hundreds of thousands of years, any face or voice that we encountered was almost unequivocally indicative of a real reciprocal social partner, someone we'd potentially interact with directly, form alliances with or even be threatened by. and our brains, as remarkably adaptable as they are, haven't fully caught up to the rapid advent of mass media. They still largely process any interaction using the same neural machinery and mental shortcuts as they would a real world interaction. And this modern day concept is really explained by something called media equation theory,
我们大脑运作的方式有时意味着你并非如此。大脑是非常古老的器官，经过数千年的演变，它们被精细地组装在一起，用于社交互动以及在部落背景下的生存。在成百上千年的时间里，我们遇到的每一张面孔或声音，几乎都毫无疑问地表明这是一个真正的、互惠的社交伙伴，是我们可能会直接互动、结盟甚至受到威胁的人。我们的大脑尽管具有非凡的适应能力，但仍未完全赶上大众媒体的快速出现。它们在很大程度上仍然使用与现实世界互动相同的神经机制和心理捷径来处理任何互动。这种现代概念实际上由一种叫做“媒体等式理论”的理论来解释，
which essentially posits that humans often interact with media as if it were really, real people or places. It's why people love to go to the friends apartment in New York. It's why people who play fictional characters on TV shows amass an abundant personal following. Our human brain is fundamentally a social brain. It's perpetually on the lookout for connections and it interprets the cues from media figures through that ingrained lens. It sees their behaviors, reactions, emotions, stories like our own. It compares them to what we're going through. So they also feel familiar. And because of that, we automatically see online personalities or media personalities similar to how we see our friends and family. There's a sense of likeness there. Another critical
该理论本质上假定，人类经常与媒体互动，就好像它们真的是真人或地方一样。这就是为什么人们喜欢去纽约的《老友记》公寓。这也是为什么在电视节目中扮演虚构角色的演员能够积累大量个人粉丝的原因。我们的人类大脑从根本上说是一个社交大脑。它永远在寻找连接，并通过这种根深蒂固的镜头来解释来自媒体人物的线索。它将他们的行为、反应、情绪、故事视为我们自己的。它将它们与我们正在经历的事情进行比较。所以它们也感觉很熟悉。正因为如此，我们自然而然地将网络红人或媒体人物视为我们看待朋友和家人类似的方式。其中有一种相似感。另一个关键
reason for this lies in the perceived control that parissocial relationships offer, which I think is also why they are on the rise. Unlike real-life friendships, which demand consistency, they demand effort. You have to make time. You have to make plans. Sometimes there is conflict, sometimes there is awkwardness, there is vulnerability. Parassocial relationships are always available and they're always kind of easy. There's virtually no risk of direct rejection because they don't actually know you. There's no conflict. There's no social anxiety that is often associated with traditional interpersonal interactions.
原因在于拟社会关系所提供的感知控制力，这也是我认为它们正在兴起的原因。不像现实生活中的友谊，需要一致性，需要努力。你必须腾出时间。你必须制定计划。有时会有冲突，有时会有尴尬，会有脆弱。拟社会关系随时可用，而且它们总是很轻松。几乎没有直接拒绝的风险，因为他们并不真正了解你。没有冲突。没有通常与传统人际互动相关的社交焦虑。
You are in complete control. You decide when to watch, when to listen and crucially when to simply, when to simply. turn it off. This aspect can be incredibly appealing, especially for individuals who might struggle with social anxiety or who might harbor a real deep, seated fear of rejection in their real world interactions. Parascial relationships, their power is that they can offer a low-risk avenue for experiencing social connection. It's also important to understand that not all parasycial relationships are created equal. They operate on what we call a continuum of intensity. So it's not that they simply exist or don't exist. There's different levels to
你拥有完全的控制权。你决定什么时候看，什么时候听，最重要的是，什么时候简单地、什么时候简单地关掉它。这种方面可以具有极大的吸引力，特别是对于那些可能与社交焦虑作斗争，或者在现实世界的互动中怀有真正深重的拒绝恐惧的个人。拟社会关系的强大之处在于，它们可以为体验社交连接提供一条低风险的途径。同样重要的是要明白，并非所有的拟社会关系都是生而平等的。它们在我们所说的强度连续体上运作。所以并不是说它们简单存在或不存在。这其中有不同的级别，
it. In particular, there are three different levels of parasycial relationships that we might develop. At the mildest and most common end, you have entertainment social, parasocial relationships. This is where your engagement is primarily for enjoyment. You appreciate a celebrity's work. You appreciate Beyonce's albums. You might casually follow their life updates. You might, you know, chat about them with your friends. It's light, it's fun, it's relatively low stakes. It doesn't involve a deep emotional investment. It's not taking away from your daily life. It's just really like enjoyment and passive entertainment. Moving along the spectrum, we encounter intense personal parasocial relationships. Here, there is a considerably stronger emotional investment. You
特别是，我们可能会发展出三种不同水平的拟社会关系。在最温和、最常见的一端，是娱乐性社交拟社会关系。在这里，你的参与主要是为了享受。你欣赏某个名人的作品。你欣赏碧昂斯的专辑。你可能会随意关注他们的生活更新。你可能会（你知道的）和朋友聊起他们。这是轻松的、有趣的、风险相对较低的。它不涉及深厚的情感投资。它不会剥夺你的日常生活。它真的就像享受和被动娱乐一样。沿着这个光谱继续，我们会遇到强烈个人拟社会关系。在这里，有相当强烈的情感投资。你
feel like they can influence your decisions, influence your purchasing decisions, influence what you're wearing, you experience strong empathy, deep loyalty, you might even perceive them as a friend or a kindred spirit, whilst you typically still retain the cognitive awareness that it's not real life, it's not a two-way relationship, there is this real emotional depth. You do sometimes think like, huh, I could probably be friends with that person. Like, if I had the chance, chance to meet whoever it was, like, we would get along. There's a strong sense of pride in their achievements as well, a genuine sadness in their setbacks. So for individuals with entertainment social and even intense personal parasocial relationships, the benefits might actually be quite
觉得他们可以影响你的决定，影响你的购买决定，影响你的穿着，你体验到强烈的同理心、深厚的忠诚度，你甚至可能将他们视为朋友或灵魂伴侣，虽然你通常仍然保留着这不是现实生活、这不是双向关系的认知意识，但这里存在着这种真实的情感深度。你有时会想：“哼，我可能可以和那个人做朋友。”“如果我有机会遇到无论是谁，我们都会相处的很好。”对他们的成就有一种强烈的自豪感，对他们的挫折有一种真诚的悲伤。因此，对于具有娱乐性社交甚至强烈个人拟社会关系的个人来说，其好处实际上可能相当
significant. A very groundbreaking 2024 study that was published in nature actually discovered that parisocial bonds actually alleviate feelings of loneliness and they also help with emotional regulation. So you're sad, you're angry, you're heartbroken, you listen to your favorite artist, you feel comforted, you listen to your favorite podcast, you feel better about a situation, not just because of the information they're providing, but because of the fact that it feels comforting, it feels like a friend. Another study that was done in 2018 for the Journal of Broadcasting and Electronic Media found that parissocial relationships can also buffer the negative effects of social isolation, particularly when we are really limited in terms of social contact. So if you think about it during COVID, this was incredibly powerful. Why do you think TikTok, so many people got famous on TikTok during COVID?
显著。2024年发表在《自然》杂志上的一项具有突破性的研究实际上发现，拟社会纽带实际上可以减轻孤独感，它们也有助于情绪调节。所以你难过了，你生气了，你心碎了，你听你最喜欢的艺术家的歌，你感到安慰，你听你最喜欢的播客，你对某种情况感觉更好了，不仅因为他们提供的信息，还因为这种感觉很安慰，感觉像个朋友。2018年为《广播与电子媒体杂志》所做的另一项研究发现，拟社会关系还可以缓冲社交隔离的负面影响，特别是当我们社交接触真正受限的时候。所以如果你仔细想想，在新冠疫情期间，这是极其强大的。你为什么认为TikTok上那么多人因为新冠而走红？
because people were looking for ways to interact with others that mimicked real-life contexts, that mimicked real-life joy and friendship, and it provided a sense of healthy distraction from stress. I think really valuably, parasocial relationships, they also serve as a really powerful source of social learning and role-modeling. In a modern, you know, media landscape, people like, I don't know, I'm trying to come up with names. Like people like Alex Earle, people like Taylor Swift, think about your favorite influencer,
因为人们在寻找与他人互动的方式，这些方式模仿了现实生活的情境，模仿了现实生活中的快乐和友谊，它提供了一种健康的压力转移方式。我认为非常宝贵的是，拟社会关系也是社会学习和榜样的强大来源。在现代（你知道的）媒体环境中，像（我不知道，我正在想名字）。像亚历克斯·厄尔这样的人，像泰勒·斯威夫特这样的人，想想你最喜欢的网红，
your favorite artist. They provide a template for how you want your life to be in a way. They help you define your values, your ethical stances. They help you envision potential career aspirations. They help you make fashion choices. They help you make, you know, career and education choices, relationship choices. They kind of provide. like a subtle social script for growing up and for interacting with the real world.
你最喜欢的艺术家。在某种程度上，它们为你想要的生活提供了一个模板。它们帮助你定义你的价值观、你的道德立场。它们帮助你展望潜在的职业抱负。它们帮你做时尚选择。它们帮你做（你知道的）职业和教育选择、关系选择。它们提供了一种。成长和与现实世界互动的微妙社会剧本。
A lot of people who are lifelong fans of certain musicians or certain actresses or certain people will tell you like they first discovered them when they were quite young. This person has followed them through their life chapters. You know, I know I'm talking about Taylor Swift a lot, but she's probably the person I have the deepest parasycial relationship to because, you know, when I was six, that's like the first album that my dad bought me. And when I was 14, you know, I went to New York and I went to all of her favorite spots that she talked about in like a Vogue interview. And it was almost like, oh, she is this guidance for me. And like her albums would bookmark certain life experiences I was
许多成为某些音乐家、某些女演员或某些人的终身粉丝的人会告诉你，他们是在自己很小的时候第一次发现他们的。这个人一直陪伴着他们度过人生的各个阶段。我知道我一直在谈论泰勒·斯威夫特，但她可能是我建立最深厚拟社会关系的人，因为（你知道的）当我六岁时，那是我爸爸给我买的第一张专辑。当我14岁时（你知道的），我去了纽约，去了她在《Vogue》采访中谈到的所有她最喜欢的地方。这几乎就像是，哦，她对我的这种指导。就像她的专辑会为我正在经历的某些生活经验做书签，而这些经验是她在我的朋友们经历之前就经历过的。所以你真的会看到，就像，他们是终生的伴侣。他们感觉像是一个你可以信任的人，因为他们永远不会伤害你。而且，因为他们富有、出名而且通常很漂亮，他们有一种生活方式，让你觉得，哇，如果我的生活更像那样，就会好得多。这是他们真正赚钱的核心部分。不仅是因为他们看起来像个朋友。而是因为他们身上有一部分是高不可攀的。这种高不可攀背后有一种奇怪的经济学：正因为他们高不可攀，他们才可以向你推销东西，其理念是如果你拥有那个东西，你就会更像他们。如果你喝他们品牌的饮料，你就会更
having that she went through before my friends went through. And so you really see that it's like, they're a companion for life. They feel like, someone you can trust because they'll never hurt you. And they, because they are wealthy and famous and often beautiful, there's this lifestyle they have that you think, wow, if my life was more like that, it would be much better. That's a core part of how they really make money. It's not just that they seem like a friend. It's that there's a part of them that's unattainable. And there's a weird kind of economics to the fact that because they're unattainable, they can sell you things with the idea that if you have that thing, you'll be more like them. If you drink their branded drink, you'll be more
像他们。如果你穿着他们穿的、他们卖的衣服，你就会更像他们。如果你听他们的音乐，如果你采纳他们的生活方式，如果你购买同样的周边，无论是什么，你都可以成为他们。难道你的生活不会更快乐吗？难道你不会成为一个更好的自己吗？所以他们有时也是比较目标。他们提出了我们可能想成为什么样的人、我们可以向谁 aspir（追求、看齐）的想法。无论是好是坏，这都取决于你。对某些人来说，（你知道的）这种向上的社交比较相当具有激励作用；对其他人来说，它会让他们感觉真的很糟糕，并可能导致一种更酸溜溜的连接。这种关系变得无所不包。它变得异常强烈。这就是你。这就是
like them. If you wear the clothes that they wear and that they sell, you'll be more like them. If you listen to their music, if you adopt their lifestyle, if you buy the same pedism, whatever it is, you could be like them. And wouldn't your life be so much happier? Wouldn't you just be a better version of you. So their comparison targets sometimes as well. They present this idea of who we might want to be, who we can aspire towards. Whether that's a good or a bad thing, it's up to you. For some people, you know, that kind of upward social comparison is quite motivating for other people. It can make them feel really terrible and it can lead into a more sour kind of connection. The relationship becomes all consuming. It becomes intense. This is what you. This is what
我想要在这个简短的休息之后探讨的内容。当拟社会关系变得不健康时会发生什么？请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》，我将在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，剖析展现精神坚韧、体能以及培养复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话。去超越主导健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上具有炎症性。
I want to explore after this short break. What happens when a parasocial relationship turns unhealthy? Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more. to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索T-W-O-P-C-E-N-T。任何男人都应该遵守的两条黄金法则。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定把命运掌握在自己手里。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女友们》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross Double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗丝在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now
我随时准备谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道，我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看到这其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了台面上。
so Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years for black people in American history
所以，谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的，对我和我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的课》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾展开了对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地成为一个好人。和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难成长的课》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio App。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。所以我们在谈论拟社会关系，好的、极好的、坏的、丑陋的。是什么让这些伪关系几乎变得危险？所以在我们之前讨论过的拟社会量表的极端和最罕见的一端，你会发现 borderline（边缘型）病态拟社会关系。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. So we're talking about parasycial relationships, the good, the great, the bad, the ugly. What makes these kind of pseudo-relationships almost dangerous? So at the extreme and rarest end of that parosocial scale we were talking about before, you find borderline pathological parasitial relationships.
天哪，把这句话说七遍。边缘型病态拟社……对，你看，连一遍都说不出来。这些是最不常见且在导航时可能最令人担忧的。所以在这些情况下，个人开始失去对他们关于媒体人物的思想和感觉的控制。有时现实的界限变得极其模糊。他们可能会产生真正互惠的妄想。他们可能会相信媒体人物真正了解他们，或者有一天会回应他们的爱意。
My God, say that seven times. Borderline pathological parasit. Yeah, see, can't even say it once. these are the least common and potentially the most concerning to navigate. So in these cases, the individual can begin to lose control over their thoughts and their feelings concerning the media figure. Sometimes the lines of reality are incredibly blurred. They might develop delusions of actual reciprocity. They might believe that the media figure truly knows them or will one day respond to their affections.
天哪，把这话重复七次。简直是病态的寄生关系。是的，你看，连一次都说不出来。这些是最不常见但在处理时潜在最令人担忧的。因此，在这些情况下，个人可能会开始失去对他们关于媒体人物的想法和感觉的控制。有时现实的界限变得极其模糊。他们可能会产生真正相互回应的妄想。他们可能会相信媒体人物真的了解他们，或者有一天会回应他们的爱意。
You hear stories of people believing that, you know, Drew Barrymore is sending them messages through their TV to come and whisk her away or of people breaking into celebrities' houses because they think that they have been invited. What factors cause someone to create this more intense form of parasocial activity? Well, it's definitely linked to certain mental health disorders, particularly psychosis and schizophrenia, but individuals experiencing chronic loneliness, heightened social anxiety, introversion, lower self-esteem, or who have a stronger psychological desire for escape may be a lot more prone to forming these intense relationships.
你会听到这样的故事：有人坚信，你知道的，德鲁·巴里摩尔（Drew Barrymore）通过电视向他们发送信息，让他们去把她带走；或者有人私闯名人的住宅，因为他们觉得对方已经邀请了他们。究竟是什么因素导致某人产生这种更强烈的类社会交往形式呢？嗯，这绝对与某些心理健康障有关，特别是精神病和精神分裂症，但经历慢性孤独、社交焦虑加剧、内向、自卑，或者内心对逃避有更强烈心理渴望的个体，可能会更容易建立这些 Intense 的亲密关系。
For example, there is this model known as the absorption addiction model that helps explain why people often engage in extreme celebrity worship. And essentially what it says is that they do that to close. compensate for some other kind of deficiency in their life. Something is lacking in their life. They have a difficulty forming intimate relationships. They lack identity. They lack career stability.
例如，有一个被称为“吸收-成瘾模型”的理论，它有助于解释为什么人们经常沉迷于极端的崇拜名人。本质上，该理论指出，他们这样做是为了弥补生活中的某种其他缺陷。他们的生活中缺少了某些东西。他们在建立亲密关系方面存在困难。他们缺乏自我认同。他们缺乏职业稳定性。
They're having difficulty adjusting to life's like psychological demands. And having this fictional relationship with someone fills that hole for them. It fills that sense of yearning and longing. So according to this model, initially, the intense focus on the celebrity gives someone a real sense. of satisfaction. This motivates them to become even more intensely attached. This is the absorption stage of the model. They absorb parts of this person into their own identity. This fulfillment then becomes addictive. The more they engage with content, the more they feel a sense of belonging. The more they feel like someone is really speaking to them, the more that they feel like someone is really speaking to them.
他们在适应生活中的种种心理需求时感到困难。与某人建立这种虚构的关系填补了他们心中的那个空洞。它填补了那种渴望与期盼的感觉。因此，根据这个模型，最初，对名人的强烈关注会给人一种真实的满足感。这会促使他们产生更强烈的依恋感。这就是该模型的吸收阶段。他们将这个人的部分特质融入到自己的身份认同中。这种满足感随后会变成一种瘾。他们与内容的互动越多，归属感就越强，他们越觉得某人在真正对他们说话，他们越觉得某人在真正对他们说话。
likely it is for them to engage in thrill-seeking behavior, stalking, trying to gain some sense of mental, physical, emotional closeness to the individual. These relationships act as a secure base for that individual, especially if real-life attachments are inconsistent. But what actually, what actually ends up happening is if it becomes completely demented, it becomes completely overwhelming and because they've spent so much time in the world and the mind of this person they admire, they can't distinguish what is normal behavior and a normal approach to this individual. The biggest risk beyond obviously danger to both parties that comes from these intense kind of parasycial relationships is that they can become a replacement for real reciprocal
他们就越有可能从事寻求刺激的行为、跟踪行为，并试图对该个体获得某种精神、身体或情感上的亲密感。这些关系充当了该个体的安全基地，特别是如果现实生活中的依恋关系不稳定的话。但实际上，最终发生的情况是，如果这种关系变得彻底失控，就会变得完全不堪重负；而且因为他们花在所钦慕之人的世界和心灵中的时间太多了，以至于他们分不清什么是正常行为、对这个人的正常接近方式是什么。除了对双方显而易见的危险之外，这种强烈的类社会关系带来的最大风险在于，它们可能会取代现实中的双向关系。
bonds. If parasocial relationships fill the void left by a lack of genuine friends, or family bonds, it can actually lead to greater isolation in the long run. There's an over-reliance, particularly because there's an ease. It's easier to be and to relate to someone who you're never going to meet versus having to maintain face-to-face connections. But what happens when the person at the center of these parasocial relationships doesn't live up to our expectations? what happens when they do something wrong, when they express political views that are different
如果类社会关系填补了缺乏真诚朋友或家庭纽带所留下的空白，从长远来看，这实际上会导致更严重的孤立。人们会产生过度依赖，尤其因为这太轻松了。与一个你永远不会见面的人相处和建立联系，要比维持面对面的关系容易得多。但是，当这些类社会关系中心的那个人没有达到我们的期望时，会发生什么呢？当他们做错了什么，当他们表达了与你不同的政治观点时
to yours, when they do something scandalous, you know, Charlie X, X, X, like, did a bunch of work for H&M and a lot of people were like, that's not who I thought, you know, Brat Girl Summer was or whatever it is. You know, these people are real humans with their own motivations and teams of people telling them what's best and they deal with every other, every motion that you've experienced they are experiencing. obviously like under the limelight, they're not always going to do everything right. But if we have an intense psychological and parissocial connection to them, it can feel like they've done something wrong to us.
与你的观点不同，当他们做出丑闻时，你知道的，查莉·X·X·X（Charli XCX）为H&M做了大量工作，很多人都说，这不是我心中的“Brat Girl Summer”或者诸如此类的人。你知道，这些人是真正的活生生的人，有他们自己的动机，有团队告诉他们什么才是最好的，他们经历着你所经历过的每一种情绪。显然，在聚光灯下，他们不可能凡事都做得对。但是，如果我们对他们有着强烈的心理和类社会连接，就会觉得他们对我们做了错事。
There's severe grief. There's anger. There's a sense of disappointment. There's a sense of like having to unfriend them almost, not engage with them anymore. Like you would with a friend who also hurt you. This is where this idea of ownership over public figures and influences comes in. it's this overly inflated sense of entitlement or an expectation of, you know,
会有剧烈的悲伤。会有愤怒。会有失望感。会有那种几乎要和他们“绝交”的感觉，不再与他们互动。就像对待一个也曾伤害过你的朋友一样。这就是对公众人物和网红的“所有权”概念产生的原因。这是一种过度膨胀的权利感，或者一种对……的期望
relatability and reliability that no one can promise you. You know, this person does not know who you are. Like I feel like I've said that so many times, but they would have millions, some of these people have millions, millions of people who really adore them and who like them. And they can't make every single person happy. It's just absolutely impossible for their. them to keep everyone happy and also continue to build a fan base because obviously what's required for building a fan base, authenticity, authenticity leaves a lot of room for disagreement.
任何人无法向你保证的亲和力与可靠性。你知道，这个人根本不知道你是谁。我觉得这句话我已经说过好多次了，但他们有数百万——其中一些人有数百万真正崇拜他们、喜欢他们的人。他们不可能让每一个人都高兴。要让他们保持每个人都高兴，同时又继续建立粉丝群，这绝对是不可能的，因为显然，建立粉丝群所需要的是——真实性，而真实性留下了很大的意见分歧空间。
And it's so interesting that people, you know, someone will do something wrong. And yes, there are definitely things like when people do wrong that you're like, oh, that's really terrible. But people will just do something wrong that they didn't even realize or they'll use a brand that, you know, they didn't know it was bad or whatever it is. and people will go at them in the comments. And it's like, I can't believe that I ever followed you. You don't deserve any more of my attention.
有趣的是，人们，某人做错了事。是的，确实有些时候，当人们做错事时，你会觉得，哦，这真的很糟糕。但人们甚至会在他们没有意识到的时候就对他们做错的事横加指责，或者他们使用了一个他们不知道是坏的品牌，或者诸如此类的事情，人们就会在评论区疯狂攻击他们。这就好像是，我不敢相信我曾经关注过你。你不配再得到我的任何关注。
You're a terrible, disgusting person. I feel betrayed. Think about what it would be like to be on the other end of being like, you feel betrayed. Like, I don't even know who you are. And you're having such a strong visceral emotional reaction to me. And obviously, this person's going to take it on. But how did, like, can you see how odd that is to be like,
你是一个可怕、令人作呕的人。我觉得被背叛了。想想看，当处于被指责的一端时，那种感觉会是什么样：“你觉得被背叛了。等等，我甚至都不知道你是谁。而你却对我有如此强烈、发自内心的情绪反应。”显然，这个人会把这当作一回事。但是，你难道不觉得这很奇怪吗，成为
the subject of so much anger and upset that you obviously don't want to cause, but then you also don't particularly feel responsible for, but also don't really know how to handle because it's not like this is a friend who you actually owe things to. It's someone who feels like you owe them something even though you don't even know their name. So you can see how this gets really complicated, right? People are obviously entitled to their opinions and people are entitled to expect certain things of celebrities and people who have made a name from being public, but it's not a normal relationship. It's not a normal way to interact with people. It's completely abnormal. And I think it's a real contributor, these parasycial relationships. We've been
如此多的愤怒和心烦意乱的对象，这些愤怒和心烦意乱显然是你不想引起的，但同时你又并不觉得自己对此负有责任，而且也不知道该如何处理，因为这不像是一个你真正亏欠什么的朋友。这是一个让你觉得你亏欠了他们什么的人，尽管你甚至不知道他们的名字。所以你可以看出这变得有多么复杂，对吧？人们当然有权拥有自己的意见，人们也有权对名人以及靠公众知名度成名的人抱有某种期望，但这并不是一段正常的关系。这不是与人交往的正常方式。这完全是不正常的。我认为这些类社会关系是一个真正的推手。我们一直在
speaking primarily about positive ones, as in it's bringing a sense of worthwhile and bringing a sense of fulfillment to your life. But there's also negative parasocial relationships that can lead to online abuse and hate comments and trolls where people get a kick out of really hurting someone and bringing them down and they get a kick out of seeing their words and their actions hurt someone they've never met. Like I used to have a troll like that. Um, who had, I don't even know who this person is, but they were so awful to me. And every time I would block an account, a new account would pop up or yeah, I knew, I couldn't tell if it was the same person, although I was pretty sure would pop up and just start all over again. And I always had this fear. I was like,
主要谈论积极的方面，比如它给你的生活带来了价值感和充实感。但也有消极的类社会关系，它们会导致网络虐待、仇恨评论和喷子现象，这些人以真正伤害他人、贬低他人为乐，他们看到自己的言论和行为伤害了一个从未谋面的人会感到兴奋。就像我以前也有过这样的喷子。嗯，我甚至不知道这个人是谁，但他们对我的态度太恶劣了。每当我拉黑一个账号，就会冒出一个新账号，或者，是的，我知道，我分不清是不是同一个人，虽然我很确定，它会再次冒出来，然后一切重新开始。我总是有一种恐惧。我想：
is this someone I know? Is this someone whose feelings I've accidentally hurt in the past? Because how could anyone be this invested in harming me if they didn't actually know me? And it turns out it's really not all that uncommon these days. The rate of celebrity stalking, the rate of celebrity worship, the rate of thrill-seeking behavior towards celebrities, the rate of online harassment is going up or comes down to this strange relationship that we feel like we have this strange sense of ownership over people online. I think it's really important with that in mind to be really mindful with how you engage with individuals who you believe you are forming a parasocial relationship with. To be really self-aware around the fact that this is not
这会是我认识的人吗？这会是我过去不小心伤害过其感情的人吗？因为如果他们根本不认识我，怎么会有人如此热衷于伤害我呢？事实证明，如今这其实并不那么罕见。名人跟踪率、名人崇拜率、针对名人的寻求刺激行为率、网络骚扰率都在上升，这一切都归结于这种奇怪的关系——我们觉得我们对网络上的人有一种奇怪的所有权感。我认为考虑到这一点，非常重要的一点是，在与那些你认为自己正在与之建立类社会关系的人互动时，要保持清醒的觉悟。对以下事实保持高度的自我觉察：这不是
real. A relationship is a two-way street. This is a one-way street. As much as you might really care about them and much as you are very invested in their life, the moment that you start to feel like they owe you something, the moment that you start to feel like your emotions are tied to what they're doing, the moment that you start to find that you are going to their page, going to their Instagram, going to their website, whatever it is, so repeatedly that they are a major thought pattern for you and take up a lot of mental space, you do need to kind of pull it back. Monitor whether this over-reliance on this fictional person or this online persona or this celebrity is maybe making up for a deficiency in another area of your life.
真的。关系是双向的。这是一条单行道。尽管你可能真的很在乎他们，尽管你对他们的生活投入了极大的关注，但当你开始觉得他们欠你什么的那一刻，当你开始觉得你的情绪与他们的所作所为息息相关的那一刻，当你发现自己不断地访问他们的主页、他们的Instagram、他们的网站或者其他什么地方，频繁到他们成为你脑海中的主要思维模式并占据了你大量的心理空间时，你确实需要收敛一下了。监控这种对这个虚构的人、这个网络人设或这个名人的过度依赖，是否正在弥补你生活中另一个领域的缺陷。
It's really important to understand that. If you're leaning too far into this person's persona or to the world they've created, can you identify if there is perhaps another need? that is not being met. For example, a sense of companionship. If that's what you're struggling with, I have a whole episode on making friends on your 20s, but you really need to start seeking out real world interaction.
理解这一点非常重要。如果你过于倾心于这个人的个人人设或是他们创造的世界，你能识别出是否还有另一个需求？没有得到满足。例如，对陪伴的需求。如果这正是你所挣扎的，我有一整期关于二十多岁如何交朋友的节目，但你真的需要开始寻求现实世界的互动。
Go to the same places, the same clubs, the same gym classes, the same cafes as part of your routine at the same times, meet people that way. Go and do friendship nights or meetups or dinner with strangers in your local area, asked to be introduced to mutual friends, put more effort in with work colleagues, note and notice that an over-reliance on what's happening in someone's online life might be because of a lack of something happening in your offline life. And really understand that although a parasocial relationship might be, might feel perfect,
作为你日常生活的一部分，在固定的时间去相同的地方、相同的俱乐部、相同的健身课、相同的咖啡馆，用这种方式认识人。去参加交友之夜、聚会，或者和当地的陌生人共进晚餐，请求通过共同的朋友认识，在同事身上投入更多精力，注意并意识到，对某人网络生活的过度依赖，可能是因为你线下生活的某种缺失。并且要真正明白，尽管类社会关系可能是、可能会感觉很完美，
you're missing out on a really core ingredient when it comes to nourishing relationships, which is the messiness and the vulnerabilities. That's what makes love and platonic intimacy and connection so real and necessary for longevity is that it challenges us and it allows us to grow and it allows us to feel trust and vulnerability and to feel growth and attachment to someone. There is no replacement for this. There is no replacement for that at all, nothing in this world that someone, an online media persona, could ever feel.
你在滋养关系的道路上错过了一个真正的核心要素，那就是混乱与脆弱。正是这一点让爱情、柏拉图式的亲密关系和连接变得如此真实，并且对长久关系而言是必不可少的，因为它挑战了我们，让我们得以成长，让我们能够感受到信任、脆弱，以及对某人的成长与依恋。没有什么可以替代这一点。没有什么可以完全替代它，世上没有任何东西能比得上线上媒体人设所能给予的感受。
So just make deliberate concentrated efforts to mindfully engage, to have a few digital detoxes every now and again, regularly schedule and commit to breaks from social media or a particular kind of content. That's really going to help reduce that constant exposure and really critically evaluate the content you're consuming. Especially when it comes to influencers promoting certain products or lifestyles. Let me tell you this once more. A lot of that is curated to sell you something. A lot of what you see from very famous influencers is a lot of trial and error from their part until they've found something that clicks and that works and then replicating that over and over again in a way that might feel authentic for you, but is perhaps not. There's a lot of filters going on.
因此，只需刻意、集中地努力进行有意识的互动，每隔一段时间进行几次数字排毒，定期安排并承诺暂停使用社交媒体或某种特定内容。这确实有助于减少持续的接触，并真正批判性地评估你所消费的内容。特别是在网红推广特定产品或生活方式方面。让我再对你说一次。其中很多都是为了向你推销东西而精心策划的。你从非常著名的网红那里看到的很多内容，都是他们经历了一次次的试错，直到找到某种能引起共鸣并奏效的东西，然后以一种对你来说可能觉得真实、但实际上可能并非如此的方式一次又一次地复制。这里面有很多滤镜。
There's a lot of body modification through online editing that goes on. There is so much that you don't see. and I know you might not need that reminder because you're a smart, intelligent person, but even if you think you're immune to it, you are not. I am not. And I'm friends with people like this and like not people who are inauthentic, but I'm friends with people who work in media who we talk about this all the time. And even then I'll see someone's life online and be like,
通过网络修图进行的身体改造有很多。有太多你是看不到的。我知道你可能不需要这种提醒，因为你是一个聪明、睿智的人，但即使你认为自己对它免疫，你也没有。我也没有。我和这样的人是朋友，并不是说他们不真实，而是我和在媒体工作的人是朋友，我们一直在谈论这个。即便如此，我看到别人的网络生活时还是会觉得：
oh, my life would just be better if it looked like that. That's parisocial. It's unhealthy comparison. It's unhealthy obsession with a life that has been. being displayed that is not real. So we really need to find our reality point. We really need to find our way of assessing this truthfully. I also saw this really amazing video the other day around the difference between consuming and applying. If you find that you are constantly like consuming content because you want inspiration and because you want to feel like you, like sometimes consuming content
哦，如果我的生活看起来是那样，那该有多好。这就是类社会现象。这是不健康的比较。这是对被展示出来的、并非真实的生活的不健康痴迷。所以我们真的需要找到我们的现实基准。我们真的需要找到一种真实评估它的方法。前几天我也看到一个非常棒的视频，关于“消费”和“应用”之间的区别。如果你发现自己总是像在消费内容，因为你想要灵感，因为你想让自己感觉……就像有时消费内容
feels like you're doing something, it's not the same as actually doing the thing. Consuming mass amounts of running content, consuming mass amounts of lifestyle content, of business content is not the same as putting those things into action. So this might be unrelated to parasycial relationships. Perhaps this is more around just genuine literacy and social media literacy. Make sure you are not confusing, consuming and consumption and viewing as acting and doing and cultivating a life that you want. the hours that you spend online and engaged in these online fictional worlds is time wasted most of the time.
感觉就像你在做些什么一样，但这与真正去做那件事并不是一回事。消费大量的跑步内容，消费大量的关于生活方式的内容、商业内容，并不等于将这些东西付诸实践。所以这可能与类社会关系无关。也许这更多地关乎真正的读写能力和社交媒体素养。确保你没有把消费、观赏与行动、践行以及耕耘你想要的生活混为一谈。你花在网络上并沉浸在这些网络虚构世界中的时间，大多数时候都是浪费的时间。
You know, it really is like social media is for dopamine and dopamine only. And so if you're finding that that's all you want to, all you feel drawn to, how can you turn consumption into creation and into cultivating a good life beyond the screen? Okay, we're going to take a short break. but when we return, I want to answer some of your questions, dilemmas, conundrums around parasocial relationships. There were some incredible questions for this episode. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
你知道，确实如此，社交媒体就是为了多巴胺而存在的，仅仅为了多巴胺。所以如果你发现这正是你想要的全部、你所受到的全部吸引，你该如何将消费转化为创造，转化为在屏幕之外耕耘美好的生活呢？好了，我们要休息一小会儿。但当我们回来时，我想回答你们关于类社会关系的一些问题、困境和难题。这期节目有很多精彩的问题。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧的科学、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-O-Percent”。任何男人都应该遵守两条金科玉律。规则一，永远不要惹农家女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友。
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield）。在这季全新的《女友们》（The Girlfriends）中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）莉尔·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客节目《回首往事》（Look Back at It）中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时期的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你补充完这句话。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。欢迎收听我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的
therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough
治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keir Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那件事。
because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我们仍然在追逐它，却不知道什么时候做得够多了，因为人们都在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. Let's get into our listener questions for this episode. Just as a reminder, make sure that you are
这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。让我们进入本期节目的听众提问环节。作为一个小提醒，请确保你
following us at that psychology podcast on Instagram. If you want to be able to participate in future episodes when we put the call out for any questions you may have. This first question is, why are we so obsessed with celebrity gossip? It feels so unhoused. It feels so unhoused. healthy that we are so invested in the lives of people we will never know and tear them down as if we do. Okay, so this is deeply psychological, actually. From a psychological perspective, our obsession with celebrity gossip really comes down to our, I would say, deep-rooted evolutionary instinct around social hierarchy and status. We are inherently wired to monitor where we sit in the social hierarchy as tribal creatures and particularly as well to monitor those at the top of the
在Instagram上关注我们的账号“那个心理学播客”（that psychology podcast）。如果你想在我们发出征集任何问题的号召时参与到以后的节目中。这第一个问题是：为什么我们对名人八卦如此着迷？这感觉太不健康了。这感觉太不健康了。对一些我们永远不会认识的人的生活投入如此多的感情，并像我们真的很了解他们一样去诋毁他们，这太不健康了。好吧，其实这有着深刻的心理学原因。从心理学的角度来看，我们对名人八卦的痴迷，归根结底其实源于我们根深蒂固的关于社会等级和地位的进化本能。作为部落生物，我们天生就被硬编码去监测自己在社会等级中的位置，特别是要监测那些处于
social ladder because historically that kind of helped us figure out our own position within a group celebrities are kind of like the modern day royalty right and so because of that sometimes we are hoping that they will fail in australia we have this term it's called tall poppy syndrome whereby the tallest flower is the first one to get cut down. You know, the person to succeed is the first one to be for people to wish for their failure. And I think that happens with celebrities a lot because if they fail, perhaps we think that there will be room for us or perhaps we think that that proves that no one is perfect and so we shouldn't feel bad about ourselves either,
社会阶梯顶端的人，因为从历史上看，这有助于我们弄清自己在一个群体中的定位。名人就像是现代的皇室，对吧？正因如此，有时我们甚至希望他们失败。在澳大利亚，我们有一个词叫做“高罂粟综合征”（tall poppy syndrome），意指最高的花朵往往是第一个被砍掉的。你知道的，取得成功的人往往是第一个招致人们期盼其失败的人。我认为这在名人身上经常发生，因为如果他们失败了，也许我们会觉得这样就会腾出我们的空间，或者也许我们认为这证明了没有人是完美的，所以我们也不必为自己感到糟糕，
especially considering that these individuals are often elevated as, yeah, being visions of perfection and being completely flawless. Gossip as well really plays into this as well. Gossip is a form of information sharing. It's a form of monitoring, I guess, like, moral and social rules. I also think that it's a form of escapism. So our lives feel less bad if we're able to compare them to the life of a celebrity who's having, you know, a really terrible time. It makes us feel like, oh, here is someone else who's struggling as well, who's experiencing a breakup, who's experiencing scandal or failure, and it humanizes them. And it reminds us that wealth or beauty doesn't shield anyone from life's challenges,
尤其是考虑到这些人常常被推崇为完美无瑕、毫无破绽的愿景。八卦也确实在其中起到了推波助澜的作用。八卦是一种信息共享的形式。我想，它也是一种监督道德和社会规则的形式。我也认为这是一种逃避现实的形式。如果我们能把自己的生活与一个正在经历（你知道的）非常糟糕时期的名人的生活进行比较，我们的生活就会感觉没那么糟糕。这让我们觉得，哦，这里还有另一个人也在苦苦挣扎，也在经历分手、丑闻或失败，这让他们变得更有血有肉。这也提醒我们，财富或美貌并不能保护任何人免受生活挑战的侵袭，
which is kind of nice. It kind of provides a sense of catharsis and a sense of relief. Also, there's a sense of entertainment as well. People love to be involved in things that are novel and new and scandalous and celebrity gossip is a great way to do that because they don't feel real. So the consequences of saying all the terrible things that you think and feel won't be as significant as if you said them about someone else. So this next question, I kind of debated whether to include it or not, but I thought it was interesting if you will allow me to be, I don't know, self-indulgent. I don't know. It feels strange, but I'll tell you the question. The question was, how does it feel for the receiver being you? So how do I deal with
这感觉其实挺不错的。它提供了一种宣泄感和解脱感。此外，还有一种娱乐的成分。人们喜欢参与那些新奇的、全新的、充满丑闻的事情，而名人八卦就是做到这一点的绝佳途径，因为他们感觉不真实。因此，说出你心中所想、所感的那些可怕的话，其后果不会像你对其他人说那样严重。所以下一个问题，我其实纠结过要不要把它包括进来，但我觉得这很有趣，如果你允许我表现得，我不知道，有点自我放纵的话。我不知道。这感觉有点奇怪，但我会把问题告诉你。问题是：作为接收者的你，感受如何？我是如何处理
with parisocial tendencies from listeners or from fans. I will say that the majority of people who come up to me or who I interact with who love the podcast are super respectful, super cool. I always say to people like, I have the coolest listeners. Anytime I meet any of you, I'm genuinely like so impressed. Like just really cool, inspiring, smart individuals. you guys always have such interesting things to say and I really like talking to you. I think it becomes a struggle online.
听众或粉丝带来的类社会倾向的。我想说的是，大多数走近我或与我有互动、喜爱这个播客的人都超级尊重人、超级酷。我总是对人们说：我有最酷的听众。每当我见到你们中的任何人，我都由衷地感到印象深刻。都是非常酷、极具启发性、聪明的人。你们总是有那么多有趣的话题可聊，我也真的很喜欢和你们交流。我认为问题出在网络上。
So something that I really encounter, obviously given the nature of what we talk about on the podcast, it's quite deep and vulnerable and emotional. And often people find those deep emotional episodes during really hard times for them. So I can occasionally receive messages that I don't think necessarily understand that I'm a stranger and that when I'm checking my messages and I open a message without context that tells me about something really terrible and traumatic that happens in your life, like it does impact me. And sometimes I find that strange because I've never met you. I don't know you.
因此，我真正遇到的情况是，考虑到我们在播客中谈论的内容的性质，它们往往相当深刻、脆弱且充满情感。而且人们经常在他们人生中最艰难的时期找到那些深刻的情感节目。因此，我偶尔会收到一些信息，我觉得发件人未必意识到我只是个陌生人，而且当我查看信息时，在没有上下文的情况下打开一条向我讲述你生活中发生的非常糟糕和创伤性事件的信息，这确实会对我产生影响。有时我觉得这很奇怪，因为我从未见过你。我不认识你。
I'm sure I would really like you if I did, but because there are, you know, at this stage, so many people in the community, I can't have those one-on-one relationships. So receiving those messages used to really stress me out. And I used to feel like I owed people a response because it would be really delicate stuff and I didn't want to ignore them. But I think I realized that it is more ethical to not respond versus to respond. It's more ethical for me to ignore the message because I think responding to messages gives an indicator of trust. And it kind of sends a signal that someone can continue to do that and that I will be there for. for them. And the thing is, is that I just can't be. You know, I have my own relationships. I have my own
如果我认识的话，我相信我一定会很喜欢你，但由于在这个阶段，社区里有太多人，我无法与他们建立这种一对一的关系。所以收到这些信息过去常常让我感到压力很大。我过去常常觉得我欠别人一个回复，因为这些都是非常敏感的事情，我不想忽视它们。但我认为我意识到，不回复其实比回复更有道德。对我来说，忽视这条信息更有道德，因为我认为回复信息会释放出信任的指标。这在某种程度上发出了一个信号，即某人可以继续这样做，而我将永远在那里支持他们。但问题在于，我做不到。你知道的，我有我自己的关系。我有我自己的
friends. I do, you know, I can provide solace and love and advice for them, but to do it for thousands of people would just be like really, really irresponsible. So yeah, I think that's sometimes strange. I think also it's strange when, um, I, I feel like I'm not particularly, like I don't say myself as a public figure. Like I've been very deliberate. around not becoming like an influencer personality, not because I think there's anything bad about it, just because I know how I handle public scrutiny and I don't handle it well,
朋友。我确实（你知道的）可以为他们提供安慰、爱和建议，但如果为成千上万的人这样做，那将是非常非常不负责任的。所以，是的，我觉得有时这很奇怪。我也觉得奇怪的是，嗯，我并不觉得自己特别……就像我不认为自己是一个公众人物。我有意为之，
and I just don't think I would enjoy it. So, yeah, I feel like there were opportunities for me to be more like an online personality, and I didn't take them. And sometimes I wonder if I'm going to regret that because, you know, there's more money there and there's more listeners there, and there's more appreciation there,
不让自己变成那种网红人格，倒不是因为我觉得这有什么不好，只是因为我知道自己如何应对公众的审视，而我应对得并不好，而且我只是觉得我不会享受它。所以，是的，我觉得曾经有机会让我变得更像一个网络红人，但我没有抓住。有时我怀疑自己是否会后悔，因为（你知道的）那里有更多的金钱，有更多的听众，有更多的赞赏，
you know, there's more attention there. And I'm like, oh, did I give up on an opportunity to be that kind of, you know, to be a TikTok star or whatever. But no, I think I made the right decision, not that I could have even really have done it. But yeah, there were definitely opportunities would be like, oh, do this ad series or do this collaboration or do this just general series. And I've been like, oh, I don't really want to do that. So I think I kind of avoid a large part of it.
（你知道的）有更多的关注。我会想，哦，我是不是放弃了一个成为那种人的机会，（你知道的）成为一个TikTok明星或者其他什么？但没有，我认为我做出了正确的决定，并不是说我当时真的能做到这一点。但，是的，确实有一些机会，比如，哦，做这个广告系列，或者做这个合作，或者做这个常规系列。而我都拒绝了，哦，我其实不想做那个。所以我想我某种程度上避开了很大一部分。
But even with my like deliberate attempt to not be part of that kind of ecosystem, yeah, people do still sometimes overstep boundaries. And I do find it strange, especially when they make comments around like my boyfriend, who I don't really share much about. I'm like, oh, you, like, I had someone comment like on our relationship recently. And I was like, you don't know anything about me and anything about my boyfriend. and we have such an incredibly healthy relationship. And it was so interesting to see this person coming in blind
但即便在我刻意试图不成为那种生态系统一部分的情况下，人们有时还是会越界。我确实觉得这很奇怪，尤其是当他们对我的男友发表评论时——关于他，我其实并没有分享太多。我想，哦，你……比如最近有人对我们的关系发表了评论。而我想，你对我和我的男友一无所知。我们的关系非常健康。看到这个人一无所知地介入，
and really thinking that they were saying something impactful. And genuine, they sounded like concern for me. And I was like, oh, so this is what it's like when we judge other people's relationships. Like this is, this person knows nothing. But from their perspective, they really think they do. And yeah, it was kind of a, it was interesting. But yeah, I don't think I really struggle with it, probably because of the fact that I'm not famous.
却真的觉得自己说的话很有分量，这太有趣了。说真的，他们听起来是在为我担心。而我想，哦，原来当我们评判别人的关系时，就是这样的。这个人什么都不知道。但从他们的角度来看，他们真的觉得自己知道。是的，这挺……这很有趣。不过，是的，我并不觉得这给我带来了什么困扰，可能这主要是因为我并不出名。
And the only way I think I struggle is when I feel like responsible to people to respond to really delicate messages. But I've got a healthy relationship with that now. All right. Our third question for the day, can parasycial relationships be healthy? I think yes. I think there are a lot of situations where actually they can be a source of inspiration, they can be a source of motivation, they can be a source of comfort even, especially when
我唯一觉得困扰的时候，是当我觉得自己有责任回复那些非常敏感的信息时。不过现在我对这种关系有了健康的把握。好了，我们今天的第三个问题：类社会关系可以是健康的吗？我认为是的。我认为在很多情况下，它们实际上可以成为灵感的源泉，可以成为动力的源泉，甚至可以成为安慰的源泉，尤其是当
we are fans of someone who's going through similar struggles as us, similar struggles with their identity or with their body image or with their relationship or with their finding themselves or with their gender or their sexuality. Like it's really comforting to see that you're not alone. I think especially if you are in an environment where you don't have role models like that, having a celebrity figure who is accessible and available does provide you with the script for how to live a life differently to how everyone around you is telling you to live a life. live. I think they're really crossed over when you don't have that important reality distinction, or you don't have that part of you that's like, yes, but this person doesn't know who I am.
我们是某个正在经历与我们相似挣扎的人的粉丝时，比如他们在身份认同、身体形象、感情关系、寻找自我、性别或性取向方面有着相似的挣扎。看到自己并不孤单，这真的令人感到安慰。我想特别是如果你处于一个身边没有这样榜样的环境中，拥有一个平易近人、触手可及的名人形象，确实为你提供了一份剧本，教你如何过一种与周围所有人告诉你的截然不同的生活。我认为它们真正越界的情况是，当你缺乏那种重要的现实区分能力，或者当你内心缺乏那种意识——即“是的，但这并不代表这个人认识我是谁”；
Or like, yes, but we don't actually have a relationship. So as long as you remain a fan, rather than thinking you have a friendship, I think that's, then you're pretty safe. This final question, I just thought it was really cool and I thought it was interesting. And I wanted to continue a discussion in the comments. Who is the best celebrity to worship? If you have made it this far, put a comment down the below. Who is the best celebrity to worship? Who do you think is deserving of all the parissocial relationships that come their way? My answer is Dolly Parton. I think that Dolly Parton is the best celebrity in the world. This is a podcast that was done on her a couple of years ago called Dolly Parton's America.
或者“是的，但我们实际上并没有这种关系”。所以，只要你保持粉丝的身份，而不是认为你们拥有友谊，我认为这就相当安全了。最后一个问题，我觉得这真的很酷，也很吸引人。我想在评论区继续这个讨论：谁是最好的值得崇拜的名人？如果你看到了这里，请在下方留言。谁是最好的值得崇拜的名人？你认为谁配得上所有投射到他们身上的类社会关系？我的答案是多莉·帕顿（Dolly Parton）。我认为多莉·帕顿是世界上最好的名人。几年前有一部关于她的播客节目，叫做《多莉·帕顿的美国》（Dolly Parton's America）。
It's like a six-parts series. It's so wonderful and it traces the history of America through the story of Dolly Parton. It's crazy. You've just got to listen to it to understand what I'm talking about. And it just made me learn so much more about her. And I was like, wow, you are just such a cool lady and you do so much for the community. And you have this beautiful relationship with her husband who's recently passed. That's parisotial with me that I know that. Yeah, anyway, I just really admired her.
这是一个大约六部分的系列节目。太棒了，它通过多莉·帕顿的故事追溯了美国的历史。太疯狂了。你必须去听一听才能明白我在说什么。这让我对她有了更多了解，当时我就想，哇，你真的是一个太酷的女士了，你为社区做了这么多。而且你和最近去世的丈夫有着如此美丽的关系。我知道这一点，这就是我和她之间产生的类社会关系。是的，无论如何，我真的很崇拜她。
So I think Dali Partners is up there. I think she's really, really cool. She's the first one that comes to mind. If you have another example, leave it in the comments below. But I hope that this episode was interesting to you. I hope it taught you something. I hope that it helped you understand how to navigate these relationships in a very media-saturated world. Just remember, our brains are completely, simply wide for connection.
所以我认为多莉·帕顿绝对算是一个。我觉得她真的、真的很酷。她是我第一个想到的名字。如果你有其他的例子，请留在下方的评论区。但我希望这期节目对你有所帮助，希望它教给你一些东西，希望它能帮助你理解如何在这样一个被媒体高度饱和的世界中驾驭这些关系。只需记住，我们的大脑完全、单纯地为连接而生。
And these one-sided bonds are just a sign of that inherent wiring. They're not bad. In fact, they can be very valuable. But the ultimate goal is just to be mindful and conscious around how these figures are complementing your life rather than taking from it. I think by doing so, you can really harness the benefits. So thank you for listening this far. Make sure you're following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast that you're
这些单方面的纽带只是这种天生连接倾向的标志。它们并不坏。事实上，它们可以非常有价值。但最终的目标只是保持正念，并有意识地让这些人物为你的生活增光添彩，而不是索取。我认为通过这样做，你真的可以收获其中的益处。谢谢你收听到这里。请确保在Instagram上关注我“that psychology podcast”，并
following along. You're subscribed. Whatever you are listening right now, leave a comment below based on that question I just asked. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
保持关注。订阅本节目。无论你现在在哪里收听，请根据我刚才提出的问题在下方留言。直到下一次，保重。保持善良。对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧的科学、健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-O-Percent”。
On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在播客节目《回首往事》中……对1979年来说，那对我是一个大日子。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keir Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。播客。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《迎难而上》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话
that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这在任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在一位经验丰富的持证专业人士那里进行。有多少人会随身携带一副盔甲？这向世界传达了一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。